- [Kelly] You can sit wherever you'd like.
I like your pants.
- I was told to sit in the middle.
Thanks, they don't belong to me.
- Oh, you know, yeah.
I'll give this back too, I get you.
We can only wear it once.
- [Colin] Do you get to
keep some stuff though?
- Sometimes I keep it,
because I'll probably
keep the shirt, yeah.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
I was thinking that when you were singing.
- Yeah, I keep the like,
really casual stuff, Colin.
I don't keep the dresses.
Wait, so I love music so much,
but I love asking people
that come on the show,
like, what you're listening to?
Like what are you into?
- Oh God, I listen to everything.
I listen to anything from Elvis to...
- Oh.
- U2.
- I almost gave you Elvis vinyl.
Dang it.
I almost gave you Elvis vinyl.
- [Colin] I saw there
was a record in the bag.
- Did I give you Chris Stapleton?
- No.
- Did I? What did I end up with?
I had so many options for
you and I was like going,
it's always hard to get...
- I'm grateful for it anyway,
because I have vinyls at home.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- But I love everything.
- I didn't give you Johnny,
I almost gave you Elvis,
but I didn't give you Johnny.
- John Lee Hooker, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah, well next time.
- Some EDM.
- Oh, I like EDM.
Oh, I gave you Cage The Elephant.
- Oh, that's exactly what you gave me.
- [Kelly] I gave you Cage The Elephant.
That's who I gave you, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What is that? Who is that?
- [Kelly] Oh, you didn't
know Cage The Elephant?
- No, I don't, it's a
good journey of discovery.
- Well, you're welcome.
- Yeah, it's a journey of discovery.
- Journey of discovery.
- Thank you.
- No, I like to like,
either give people things they might like,
or maybe something I
think they might like.
- And is that in the bent
of EDM? Is it electronic?
- [Kelly] I mean its like, its just a,
I don't know, it's like cool music.
- [Colin] Is it like safari?
- [Kelly] It's a cool, alternative music.
It's like you're on a
safari. (Kelly laughs)
- [Colin] Like Massive Attack or?
Like Massive Attack or no?
- [Kelly] No, no, it's a little different.
- Not that I'm saying that
Massive Attack are EDM.
- [Kelly] I mean, you might like it,
you might, you might not, I don't know.
- But "Hamilton", come on,
we're going straight to "Hamilton".
Let's not beat around the bush.
- [Kelly] Oh "Hamilton",
I love "Hamilton".
- I know you love "Hamilton", I was told.
- [Kelly] Yes, I was on the soundtrack.
- I know you were on the
soundtrack, I was told.
No, I wasn't told, I was told,
but by the time I was told, I knew,
because I'd heard it so many times.
Because your version of "Quiet Uptown",
is so, I mean, the original version,
all of the cast's versions are fantastic.
But your version on the
mix tape is extraordinary.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Colin] I sound like I'm
trying to say the right thing.
Have you heard it?
(audience applauds)
I try to say the right thing,
I ingratiate myself to you,
but I promise, I'm not trying to do that.
I have heard it so many times.
I've asked and a few people,
I was going to say so many,
but that's not true, but a few,
a few is a lot in this kind
of thing. (Kelly laughs)
To have a listen of it, to it.
- Yeah.
- It's so moving, I mean, you're just...
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you.
- Such an ability to, you
must be very empathetic.
- I am very empathetic, it's annoying.
- [Colin] You must be
because it's very hard, yeah.
But it's very hard not to
feel you, when you're singing.
It's extraordinary and that song...
- Well, that song...
- Is painful.
- It is painful.
Especially, when I had not seen "Hamilton"
and I had no idea what it was about
and they sent it to me and they're like,
"Oh, they were thinking
maybe you could do this".
- [Colin] They sent you the play shots?
- [Kelly] No, no, no, they
just sent me the song, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm pregnant with my son.
I'm literally pregnant, like with my son
and to hear that song for the first time,
I called my label...
- What trimester?
What trimester? That could be dangerous.
- About to pop, about to pop.
I'm so afraid of a
miscarriage, I'm terrified.
No, literally, I'm stressed.
And I heard this and I
called him like, just crying.
I was like, who...
(beeping)
Sends this to someone?
(audience laughs)
Like who does to someone,
like when they're pregnant...
- It's brutal.
- And it's so brutal, but I will say,
I ended up with Jason
over there, our producer
and we did it like, while I was pregnant.
And I think because of that,
it came across so real,
I think because I was terrified.
- I think it would've...
(beeping)
If you weren't knocked up.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
That's what we're saying,
I just want to be clear.
- Look Colin, I'm very method.
- I just want to be clear
on what we're saying.
- I'm very method and so I got knocked up,
purposely for this song.
- Of course, that would've
added to the rawness
and the fear, the sorrow of that piece.
- I cried almost every
time, it's such a...
- [Colin] It's a really...
I mean, I've seen the
show a number of times,
number of times, yeah.
- It's so good, I saw
it twice, it's so good.
- Oh, my God, yeah.
- And just that one person
created all of that.
- That's the bit that spins me out.
- Yeah, it all came from
your brain, it's rude.
- Picked up a book.
It is rude and it's ready
and he picked up a book,
in the airport about Alexander Hamilton
and then he thought, "Well this would make
a good hip-hop, rhymey
musical for three hours.
I'll take over the world with this".
Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
I mean, it's astonishing.
I was really, the first time I saw it,
in New York city, I
was baffled by the fact
that one man gave life
and breath and, and yeah.
Rhyme and rhythm to this whole...
And music, that he
wrote the music as well.
- It's so beautiful.
- God, he's so talented.
But anyway, you singing that song quite...
- [Kelly] It was a
treat to get to sing it.
I just wish I hadn't have been...
- Because you're battered
by that stage of the show.
You were terrified singing it?
- No, I was terrified singing it,
just because I couldn't get
through it. I kept crying.
- Oh, did you?
- Jason was like, "You're
going to have a breakdown".
(Kelly laughs)
- I saw you...
- Because it's so sad
about losing your son.
- You get emotional when you
sing sometimes, don't you?
- I, I, it's a thing that I do.
- Yeah.
It's gorgeous.
- It's annoying.
- I bet it is annoying,
I bet you feel like people think
that you're putting it on and all that,
because it's a cynical world.
- Well, I was also pregnant another time,
with another child on TV
and they had me sing at
the end of this big thing.
Like, it was a huge thing for my career
and I cried at that too.
I cry a lot, I'm very empathetic.
It's annoying, anyway.
- [Colin] No, it's lovely.
Yeah, "Hamilton" floors me every time
and "Jesus Christ Superstar" I've seen
and that has moved me at times.
And "Rent" used to mess me up.
- [Kelly] Now, but see...
- So, you're talking about,
you're talking about
singing a song on "Hamilton"
that is about a father
and a mother reconciling,
through the grief that they've shared.
- Yeah.
- As a result of the death of their son.
And you found that of
course, incredibly emotional,
when you were pregnant.
It's emotional anyway, you
don't need to be pregnant.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I wasn't pregnant when
I found it emotional,
(Kelly and audience laugh)
but I get why you did.
Well, like when you, when
you have a brother, who's gay
and you go and see something like "Rent"
and obviously aids and
the epidemic, in New York
is such a center piece of that musical.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And like, it was like
"Philadelphia" floored me.
- Oh my gosh, I couldn't keep it together.
- And I think it would've anyway,
but because things are so, when
things become personalized,
of course, they go in deeper, you know?
- And even speaking to
something that's happening,
in society.
- [Colin] Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
It opens it up even wider.
- But just so you know,
his name is Colt Smith
and he ruined "Rent" for me.
(Kelly laughs)
- Who's that?
- [Kelly] He was in choir with me.
And I was like, if you sing...
♪ Five hundred, 25,000 ♪
I was like, "If I hear it one more time,
I'm going to shoot myself".
- I know, I know, it can
all get a bit overbearing.
- No, it was, it's just,
if that was the musical,
when I was in high school
that everyone's sang,
at every audition that I was like,
"I can't, I can't hear it again".
(Kelly and Colin laugh)
But then I ended up going
to see my friend on it,
on Broadway, it was, it's amazing.
- Yeah and I saw the original cast,
in London with my brother.
- [Kelly] Bragger.
- And like we went and
had a bunch of margaritas
and got well oiled and
then went and saw that.
- Well oiled.
(Kelly laughs)
(Colin mumbles)
- You know?
- But this may sound weird,
but I have to ask about your cat.
Because you look like Dr.
Evil in an interview recently.
(Kelly laughs)
You did an interview and you
had your cat on your lap.
I was like, and I,
the internet wouldn't
stop talking about it,
neither would I.
Here's a look, if you missed it.
- [Colin] Oh.
(audience and Colin laugh)
I look like I'm panicking,
why am I so afraid?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
It looks like the cat might've
just... (beeping) On me.
- Oh my God, I love cats by
the way, I grew up with them.
- I love cats too.
- Yeah, how many do you have?
- [Colin] Someone, someone said to me,
we saw a thing of a cat, not this,
but something else with a cat.
they heard I had a cat and they said,
"We thought you were a dog
person". It's like... (beeping)
Can we just human beings,
not actually put lines
in the sand for once?
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Jesus...
- I can like both.
(audience applauds)
- Totally, I'm like, "No, I always thought
I was a dog person as well".
So, I was guilty of self-judgment.
But apparently I can, as
you said, I can love both.
Cats, of course.
I have two cats now,
they're brother and sister,
two rescues.
- Aw.
- [Colin] Murphy and Mia.
And they're cool man.
- [Kelly] Murphy and Mia.
- Yeah, Murphy and Mia.
Mia's is a bit, a bit...
- [Kelly] Sassy?
- She's neurotic.
(audience laughs)
She just destroys everything.
- Oh my God, my sister, I love her cat.
Her cat is old and it's a shame,
will literally, I guess
walk up and just poo,
right on her nightstand
and then look at her
and then just walk off.
(Kelly laughs)
And I'm like, that's the
difference between cats and dogs.
- We do not, they're the gifts
we do not want to receive.
- [Kelly] It's awesome.
I just, she hates it and
I love this cat so much,
because it brings me joy.
But I'm very, very
excited and so is Rubin,
who loves superhero stuff more
than me and all that stuff.
So, we're excited about "The Batman", so.
(audience applauds)
They're excited.
So, what can you tell us about it?
You play The Penguin.
- I play, yeah, I play Oz.
Who's kind of, hasn't
embodied The Penguin yet,
but is known as The Penguin basically,
because he has a bit
of a, an awkward gate.
And yeah, it was, it was, it was...
Oh yeah, there he is.
A really extraordinary makeup artist,
called, Mike Marino.
Kind of designed the character.
I would say, I can...
- Wait, wait, what?
Wait, that's not you though?
- Yeah.
- Wait, what?
(audience laughs)
I didn't see that picture, oh my God.
- [Colin] You didn't, really?
- [Kelly] I just heard
that you were Penguin.
What the hell?
- You haven't seen that?
- [Kelly] That person
deserves to win awards.
- [Colin] Oh, no, no, no, he should, yeah.
(audience applauds)
Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's you?
- [Colin] No, it's amazing.
It's amazing what he
was... And he designed,
he designed the whole thing.
- I couldn't download
the photo, last night.
And I kept telling her, I was like,
"I never saw him as Penguin".
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- The first time I saw the makeup,
was they had done a, he
had done a mold of my face.
And I saw it on a screen.
Matt Reeves' screen, the director,
the writer, director of "The Batman".
He said, "You want to see
what Mike Marino's done?
What he thinks, what he thinks
Oz is going to look like?"
And I said, "Yeah". And
he showed me the screen,
I just, I didn't know it
was going in that direction.
And I went, "Holy smoke".
And I'd never done
anything like that before.
And I can't claim...
- What kind of time did
it take to look like that?
- Four hours, four hours.
(Kelly gasps)
At the start, four hours and
then they got it down to two.
And it was fine,
because I knew that the reward
was immense and it was...
- You're a different human is the...
- It was extraordinary,
Kelly, it was so liberating.
- Did you ever go out in that?
- No, we did...
- I would've gone out in that.
- We did a test.
- And then talked...
(beeping)
About Colin Ferrell.
(Kelly and Colin laugh)
- See what people really feel.
Until you find out, they're like,
"Sorry, never heard of him".
Ooh, checked ego.
(audience applauds)
- That would've been what I would've done.
- Yeah, that experiment backfired.
(Kelly laughs)
It was amazing, yeah.
- That's crazy.
- So, I can,
I've never been able to take less,
ownership over a performance in my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
It's like so physically different, yeah.
- It's, it's like,
I don't know if it's 50/50, 49/51,
60/40, I'm not sure.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- But Mike Marino and myself
and then Matt of course wrote it.
You know, it's, it's a,
you didn't have to do much.
- So intense.
- [Colin] It was like an alchemy.
Yeah, when it went on the first time
and just, you're hidden and
you just have absolute freedom.
- Oh my God, I will never
complain about spanks again.
(audience and Colin laugh)
When you have them on for
four hours, that is a lot.
Okay so, I want to talk
about your other film.
Because one wasn't enough for you to do.
- Yeah, "After Yang".
- [Kelly] "After Yang".
So, what's it about?
- Greedy, "After Yang" is about a family,
going through, that family there,
going through...
- Beautiful family.
A version of a, of a kind
of, a crisis in a way.
It is an undescribed time in the future.
And it is a time on our planet,
where technology has
reached the stage where
you can have a living robot.
What we call it in the
film is "technosapiens".
And myself and my wife,
played by Jodie Turner Smith,
have an adopted daughter who
comes from Chinese heritage.
And we have this technosapien
to be a sibling to her.
And to also be a reference point for her.
- Like culturally?
- Yeah, her cultural information,
that she wouldn't get otherwise.
And the film opens up,
basically you see the family together
and then very quickly the
technosapien breaks down.
And it's about, the film is about grief
and about loss and about
family and about memory.
And I suppose to me, I don't know,
it's about the important moments in life.
The simple moments that
we can so easily overlook,
in striving for something that
we think will hold meaning,
that's outside of our experience.
Something that we think
will make us happy,
something that we think we can achieve
and will answer all our problems.
When in fact...
- Oh, Lord.
- We have so much...
- Have you snuck into my therapy sessions?
(Colin and Kelly laugh)
I'm like, "Wait, what?"
- [Colin] Yeah, yeah, so you
and me, both. I read it and it,
it hit me, reading the script fairly hard.
Because it was just so
beautifully written,
by the director as well, Kogonada,
he wrote the script
based on a short story.
- I love that you're doing two films.
You're promoting two films
and they're so different.
- Yeah and to be honest with you,
like "The Batman", you know,
it's great to do press for it and all,
but look, there's trailers everywhere
and there'll be posters everywhere.
And "After Yang" hasn't
really got much of a nickel
to put into stuff.
And it's a small film and it, you know,
it's not, it's not a summer blockbuster.
- [Kelly] But it seems poignant
and the message is on point.
- I think so, you know,
and people seem to,
it premiered in Sundance
and people had some very
emotional responses too,
which is unusual for me,
or anything I'm part of.
- What?
- It's nice, yeah, you know, I don't do,
well, a lot of stuff I've done
has kind of been violent or.
- [Kelly] I love that about you.
I love, that's what I
was just about to say.
- You love my violence?
- No, I love that like, you'll
be in those films though,
but you'll also do, I like
the fact that you just,
even these two films that
you, the juxtaposition...
- [Colin] And it's fun.
- It's cool.
- It's fun, honest to God, it's fun.
It is fun, it's just us,
It's just really fun.
I'm just spoiled, just get
to do different things...
- You're a completely different
human in "The Batman".
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
it's fun, love, for me.
- Remember that time I thought
they put someone else up?
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I was like, "This is rude".